kyrie irving had some controversial
comments
on kevin durant's new podcast about who
would take the last shot
in clutch situations so the refresher
member here's what he said the other day
depends on who's hot i don't see it as
anything other than that like
one three pick and roll or it's a iso
for either one of us or it's something
great for our our team i'm one thing
i've always been comfortable with is
you know i felt like i was the best
option on every team i played for
you know down the stretch this is the
first time in my career where i could
look down and be like
make that shot too
why must it always be brother against
brother
why if i'm addressing anyone
i'll say their name come on y'all don't
listen to the false narratives
let people live their lives it's just
the game
talk about the art talk about the sport
you talk openly you talk freely
but because we live in a click-bait
society it becomes something bigger
you don't have to defend it that's just
what media
is it's entertainment
i'm not gonna let it put me against
anybody anymore
at any point because that's not what
it's about we talk freely
openly and that's our society
say i feel don't have to put
me against anyone else it's never been
about that
it's about the love peace
and you can hear more from kyrie irving
as he contributes to the ongoing
entertainment around this subject
with an ig live at six o'clock this
evening six o'clock six o'clock eastern
kyrie irving sets the record straight
sets us straight in
media the media michael yeah
uh okay all right so just help me out
here
help me out i'm just going i'm trying to
follow this paper trail
paper trail started kyrie talking about
taking that last shot and i've always
been the best option
where'd that come from where where'd
that story come from
was that in the l.a new york times he
said it he said it
is his word he's on tape okay he said it
he is his words
yes then we take what he says and it's
just clear as day i've been
i'm the best option this is the first
time in my career he's played
for a long time what nine years
first time in my career that you know i
look at somebody else and like he can
make that shot
so we say well you play with lebron
james why are you you saying you're a
better option than lebron jack
he comes back and says don't believe the
media you're the storyteller in this
case
you're the storyteller who's criticizing
the storytellers
the media against the media it's you
it's kyrie versus kyrie
yeah who are you talking about so you're
the
you're the problem you're the
entertainer
you're the clickbait because it's your
whole story
for the podcast it's great for the new
podcast network i'll tell you that much
um what's she what's a little boy what
is he talking about
well i mean yeah you know it's a pet
peeve of mine uh
you know we're grammar nerds grammar
snobs kind of part of being
writers and journalists right so you
know the the their their struggle is one
uh another one is when people mess up
imply and infer
that was just like i i cringe when i
hear people confuse and apply and infer
um he's saying that we inferred that he
was talking to somebody else
when he clearly implied that he was
talking about somebody else
now here's my question can that
implication be accidental in other words
can you fire shots without necessarily
aiming them at the person whose name he
didn't mention
he claims if you were talking about him
he would say his name so if he said if i
were talking about lebron
i would say lebron but when you say this
is the first time in my career
and the and the apex of your career
was winning a championship alongside
lebron james
when you say this the first time in my
career that i can look over and i see
somebody who can make that shot too
what else are we to infer other than you
didn't feel that way about lebron james
like harry loves to believe and i and i
like kyrie i like kyrie michael he loves
to believe he's the smartest person
in every room it's like dude come on
like stop acting like we stupid
he's not for me okay you said you like
not for me but i got you
okay you like him look um
i don't think i'll give you this i don't
think he was just talking about lebron
james so he played with many
great players in his career the greatest
player he's played with in his career
is lebron but he's also played with
kevin right he's also playing with jason
tatum
yeah and gordon hayward and all those so
yeah yeah
that that's who the end whoever whoever
is was with them this year in brooklyn i
know kevin durant's on the bench where
was there
so so maybe so maybe he so is he right
then michael is
based on what you're saying that lebron
isn't the only really good
great it's a great player he's played
with you know and jason zeta might be a
little early to call him great but he's
on the cusp more people should be upset
not just lebron more people should be
okay okay so more people should be
disrespected than just lebron
yeah he essentially called on everybody
as i said to you yesterday he is that
guy
he's a guy who can he'll intrigue you
so if you are if you're steve nash and
you're looking to take a job which is
which is what
happened with him in brooklyn you're
looking to take a job
you're intrigued by kyrie irving
on the roster he's intriguing enough to
draw you to the job
and just and just destructive enough
to get you fired he'll get you fired
it's also
it's also go ahead mike i'm sorry no i
was just gonna say like the
the other thing he said and this is like
a low key thing
when you say about coaching hey the
first thing that was hockey
yeah you got well before we got into the
whole collaborative thing i really don't
see us having a head coach
well steve nash is like well why are
they paying me what
i don't really have authority here i
don't have i can't put in my system
because
we're all collaborators or
co-collaborators
yeah i don't really see us having a head
coach katie can be a head coach i could
be a head coach
jack vaughn can be a head coach that's
just two meters
that's too matter but more than that
though he said
uh you've got to respect you got to know
number one i'm a human being
yeah i'm a human being and i'm i'm going
to be about my community first
and then we can get into don't come in
and like tell me put all your systems on
me
like i'm i'm a human we know you're a
human being
like i've always said this ooh oh it was
close
i was close okay i'm gonna go there i'll
go down i don't care
he'll never win he'll never win with
this attitude
he'll never win never win against he'll
never win attitude again with this
attitude as a leader of a team as a
co-collaborator co-leader co-captain
whatever he considers himself with
with kevin durant he'll never win
because
he doesn't want to be coached
he doesn't want to be coached he told
jackie mcmullen mike
he said i'm a genius quote on the record
i am a
genius who says that who says that
like all the geniuses that we've talked
about here does dave chappelle
call himself did eddie murphy call
himself a genius do they say that
right does stevie wonder i ever say i'm
a genius
even though they are so the fact that
tell me you're jealous
yeah i'm gonna question that so he told
jackie i'm a genius when it comes to the
sport
he said about brad stevens brad stevens
has never coached anyone like me
so he's got a lot to learn and already
before steve nash
coaches one game before before he blows
the whistle the first time
he's being told don't bring your
coaching philosophy
to me we're co-collaborators
cam i just wish he was smarter when it
came to self-awareness or his lack
thereof like i said yesterday because
it's like
all right kyrie you're going on kevin
durant's podcast and okay there is
something to be said because i listen
carefully to his
you know ig clarification that we just
played i listened carefully to it now
it's like okay
you know i'm speaking freely why must it
be brother against brothers just
speaking freely
i hear you man you're speaking freely
but you got to know dude
you got to know at this point in your
career that nothing you say
to kevin durant on his podcast
the point of it is promotion nothing you
say is gonna is not gonna be scrutinized
so choose your word carefully genius be
a genius when it comes to your word
choice be smarter when it comes to what
you say because michael holly okay
if i set up here right now and say this
the first time i've ever done a tv show
with anybody who knows what they're
really talking about this is the first
time i've ever done a tv show
with somebody who's as committed to the
show as i am it's the first time i've
ever
done a tv show with somebody you know
who i can just lay out and listen to
now none of that's how i feel but if i
said that
how is that not reflective on all the
people i've worked with
before so if you're kyrie irving
yeah you're trying to compliment kevin
durant but in doing so
you implicitly and therefore we inferred
that you didn't feel that same way about
the guy who was the better player
on your team and whether you realize it
or not kyrie
was the better option down the stretch
was their best option it was their best
option now
it would be interesting if he had said
it this way look
i mean i can't tell him what to say but
it would play out differently if he then
wanted to be brother against brother
and the whole click bait and all that
stuff
one way he could say it to make his
point is i've played with some great
players
and he has i played with some great
players and some great scorers
and lebron can call them all by name
lebron is
one of the greatest players in the
history of this game
but i feel down the stretch i feel like
throwing the kd kd can give me more
options
right okay now that's not saying i'm the
best option
like kd is a better three-point shooter
than lebron right
so you could say i can hit him i can hit
him 25 feet from the basket
with two seconds left and know that's a
good shot for him
uh he can go to mid-range he's got
everything and i feel like he's the best
option
uh in that situation now
saying it that way i don't know if i
agree with that but that's not that's
not disrespectful
no but you're on to something you're
onto something because okay
if his action if his feeling is
okay if his feeling is
that let's get past the and this is
where i'm
i i see where he's kind of coming from
was that we immediately
again inferred and jumped into the okay
this is this
he he's he's whether he realizes it or
not or whether it's intentional or not
he's throwing shade at lebron
this is where i'm i'm i'm gonna go i'm
gonna sound like i'm
defending or justifying kyrie but just
bear with me go ahead defense defend him
no no no no defending but i'm just
saying like if his take
is and any listen
there is not a more creative offensive
player
or shot maker in recent memory than
kyrie irving
he's he is an offensive savant when it
comes to
listen man you got to give him that you
got it when it comes to when it comes to
his ability to get it get in line and
make a shot kyrie as you said he can do
it mike smith you came in one day with a
list of ballers
you had a list there a lot of they're a
lot of great but anyway go ahead i don't
want to distract you go ahead
okay so i'm saying if he said for the
first time
i am playing with somebody who i see as
my equal in the
area if this is what he what he thinks
in the area
of taking one shot okay
that's actually michael if you if you
really think about it
it's actually not that hot of a take
because i don't think that anybody even
though he's made a lot of big shots
i don't think that anybody if you if you
had one shot to win a game
do you want lebron james taking it over
anybody else if you have one shot to win
a game
do you want lebron taking it i want
lebron with the ball in his hand
i want lebron on the floor deciding who
takes it
and if he takes it great i'll take my
chances
but if i got one shot with game i don't
know game seven in the nba finals on the
line
it might not be lebron it might be kd
over lebron
that's not ridiculous it was it was it
was the dismissive way in which he
delivered it michael not the substance
even
of his commentary but it was like he
wasn't thinking about lebron
and it feels like it's always felt like
he was unappreciative of what lebron
helped him achieve and it felt like a
continuation of that like oh okay
you know yeah that's the first time i
ever look across see somebody who can
make that shot well lebron can make that
shot but if your point is
when you talk about just one shot that
kevin durant is one of the best you've
ever seen
at shot making that's that's that's okay
i'm okay with that
it just was i think it was more of a
delivery maybe than the intent
the defense arrests the same point you
raised an inch the defense rests
but but he did say he did say i'm the
best option
so those those two differences he said
my whole career i've always felt like i
was the first option
i was the best option so it wasn't even
like durant versus lebron it's like
it's me versus which yes which speaks to
a lot
when you go back to cleveland you wonder
how those huddles went down yeah but
but speaking of lebron where is it where
is it in there there it is
you see that lebron's intentional
comments
lebron's intentional comments